how's it going brother smell welcome to
goat simulator jesus [ __ ] christ what
is this okay it's so cute
okay let's go how'd it happen that's not
up come on up
this is [ __ ] boring oh Jesus that's
way
all right fly with it oh my god
oh I am outside the man what do I do
here Jesus kind of outside the game I
broke free from the laws of physics oh
god damn it I'm going back
that's not exactly what I had in mind
fake you faked her you're coming with me
all right let's go up here more fake go
to hell don't you try to hide treasure
from me come here you little [ __ ]
Oh No oh yeah look at my sexy buddy yeah
ha ha ha oh my god I got it I got you
unlock its hole goat I can unlock a
different type of go it's amazing what's
in here but DIF what goat castle hello
proclaim yourself as king of the night
oh there's some weird Illuminati [ __ ]
going on here man this is freaking the
[ __ ] out of me ha ha oh my god oh my god
oh my god yeah hi oh jesus oh god damn
it I knew I should we all have our ways
to dealing with an itchy anus let's be
honest
all right peasant parents has to get out
of here oh wait is that a Bratz fish
[ __ ] Yoink ok so how do I get out of
this demon portal this goat has a
striking resemblance to Miley Cyrus I
can't believe I never seen it before
okay so we unlocked
Paul gun what's tall guy frontflips
[ __ ] you thought I was the goat no
much arrived still have that sexy ass
tongue though front flips all the front
flips the best front flip is this game
just keeps amazing me man there has to
be game of the year you play as a
[ __ ] giraffe
ten out of ten baby hey guys am i late
to the party
why why does a my tongue look at that
[ __ ] oh my god
my tug is possessed what happens if I
lick people that guy keeps dancing
oh hey all right in the head
awesome this drug is so [ __ ] slow all
right so I know there's something here
that we haven't checked out yeah this
whole I saw this old before go inside
don't be a [ __ ] you're a giraffe
oh god what's gonna happen what nothing
to say here am i changing sides I think
I'm changing sighs Oh am i tiny oh Jesus
cries I'm huge all right maybe now we
can block this [ __ ] now my god oh I
think I broke every bone in my body all
got knotted guys jump over nailed it how
do I get over yes nailed it how do I get
in
Oh mail that to come on how do I go
inside I know I'm a little fat but that
has never stopped anyone but god damn
okay there we go we finally broke it
don't worry you're fighting you're up
oh we're fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm not
fine I'm fine I'm fine
tonight yeah but seriously I want to go
into factory hopefully I hope you're not
any giraffes are watching this and they
get offended
honestly I don't mean anything bad at
all oh come on not this [ __ ] again for
[ __ ] sake
what even happened there all I wanted
was to be a giraffe no one ever told me
I wasn't allowed don't [ __ ] out on me
now oh Jesus oh no that's my worst
nightmare oh I'm so sorry back out and
I'm fine I'm fine I am NOT fine I'm
never fine
oh thank God I made it out alive
is the worst day of my life and the best
kiss I'm a giraffe [ __ ] I'm a giraffe
[ __ ] look at my ass shake look I'm an
ass shake you can see my balls you can
see my balls you can see my balls anger
lately huh you can see my bow you can
see my giraffe balls go drive my own rap
God rap God rap God rap out your brass
balls go now we can go girl never can go
now we can go Vera nailed it go for
Jesus what the [ __ ]
Oh God what is that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is that
okay that's the normal day actually I
want to skate first
all right let's skate skating giraffe
style yeah oh oh come on do a kickflip
nailed it
hey no skating like giraffe skating you
think you know skating
well you haven't [ __ ] tried you rat
oh god it's at my penis awesome
come on go inside please
oh yeah I'm the sexiest [ __ ]
animal in the earth all the front lifts
all the front flips on the front flips
being a giraffe is the best thing ever
freaking Drive it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Wow
app what goes on in this cage what just
happened to me what is happening barrel
Jason what is that look at that [ __ ]
nice very attractive oh nice
[ __ ] nice man neckbreaker simulator
2013 14 [ __ ] it I don't [ __ ] know
oh there's stuff going on up here what
the [ __ ] is this
oh Jesus Christ not Illuminati [ __ ]
again gather sacrifices I can't do that
that yes my lord we will collect them
have with me if you want to live Armen
what the [ __ ] okay little [ __ ] come
with me what happened to Arman Arman you
won't hurtin him will you
alright let's find some more people to
kill you come with me sir auch what the
[ __ ] hey oh [ __ ] sorry out ladder
giraffe that's how it's done
almost Oh what is that what is that
another statue yes coffee stain serious
eye isn't that the ones that made the
game let's see if I can say yes yes
it'll build houses oh Jesus
[ __ ] I shouldn't have tacos it's -
alright
I am completely stuck this time alright
brother I gotta end this episode here I
[ __ ] love this game so much it's so
awesome leave a like if you enjoyed as
well I will be making more as long as
you do it's a scar convert the day I see
you bros tomorrow
love you brah